la pressione sociale esiste ha un peso
fisico ce ne rendiamo conto meglio
quando non è esercitata su di noi ma su
qualcuno che amiamo
quando ho messo al mondo una piccola
donna mi sono resa conto di cosa
supportano le donne fin dalla loro
nascita
viviamo in un mondo in cui ci sono molti
modi giusti per essere un uomo e nessun
modo giusto per essere una donna e
viviamo in questo mondo da molto
moltissimo tempo fare o non fare figli
separa le donne tutte le persone possono
fare un sacco di cose ma solo le donne
possono fare altre persone
a un certo punto della tua vita se sei
donna o sei madre o non lo sei
che questa cosa ti capiti o che sia una
scelta
in qualsiasi caso sarai sbagliata se io
dico madre nella testa di ognuno di voi
si apre un grande catalogo di virtù e di
azioni spesso inconciliabili che
spettano di diritto e di dovere a una
madre c'ero anch'io naturalmente anche
se aver a che fare coi figli ogni giorno
è un buon allenamento per mettere in
discussione i propri preconcetti
io ho sempre voluto fare un sacco di
cose nella vita diventare madre non è
mai stato nei miei piani
e poi è successo a me questo evento
magico meraviglioso si è abbattuto sulla
mia esistenza come un'ascia
d'improvviso era un bivio
come avrei potuto continuare ad essere
la persona che desideravo diventare e
allo stesso tempo essere una buona madre
intorno a me tutti sorridevano erano
felici entusiasti loro io non mi sono
mai sentita così sola
la maternità mi ha insegnato un sacco di
cose ad esempio che ho molta più
pazienza di quello che pensavo che non
dormire per settimane si rimette in
forma splendida
una dieta che tutti i genitori conoscano
che lo schifo può manifestarsi in forme
assolutamente inimmaginabile sconosciuto
e tutte da un esserino delizioso e
tenero ma soprattutto che il futuro è
una dimensione reale che possiamo
abitare solo se restiamo ancorati con il
nostro passato privare la vita di una
delle due dimensioni prima l'altra di
senso
mia figlia è nata una domenica notte di
fine estate
qualche giorno dopo ero a casa
credo che fosse notte a quello ti prendi
cura di un neonato e soprattutto nei
primi giorni il tempo è una dimensione
relativa infatti einsten ha inventato la
teoria dello spazio tempo quando è
diventato padre
lo ricordo come se fosse adesso
un'infermiera emozionata dall'altra
parte di un telefono che aveva appena
squillato mi chiedeva se mia figlia
stesse bene
le analisi neonatali avevano rivelato
che viola soffre di una sindrome
genetica rara
tutti i miei buoni propositi di essere
una buona madre erano falliti da
principio era una pessima madre con un
cattivo sangue avevo fatto una figlia
malata non mi sono mai sentita così
sbagliata
dal giorno dopo mia figlia entrata in
terapia ma quella notte tra il 5 e il 6
settembre 2009 io non ho chiuso occhio
in quel momento così difficile in cui
tutto è andato in frantumi
io ero pezzi non sapevo cosa sarebbe
successo il giorno dopo
nessuna persona viva poteva capirmi o
aiutarmi in quella notte ho incontrato
la donna che mi ha cambiato la vita una
ragazza morta
l'avete vista anche voi nel cinema nei
videoclip sulle copertine dei dischi nei
cataloghi d'arte nei cataloghi delle
mostre di fotografia l'hanno
soprannominata il suicidio più bello del
mondo
o più semplicemente folle body il
cadavere precipitato per decenni l'arte
il cinema la fotografia hanno reso
omaggio alla bellezza del suo ritratto
funebre ma di lei di chi fosse della sua
storia
nessuno si è mai interessato nella sua
solitudine mi sono rispecchiata il suo
nome era evelyn mchale
aveva 23 anni quando la mattina del
primo maggio 1947 si è lanciata dalla
terrazza più alta dell'empire state
building
dietro di lei un vuoto di domande e un
brevissimo biglietto d'addio
non voglio che nessuno mi veda nemmeno
la mia famiglia vi supplico fatemi
cremare distruggete il mio corpo
niente funerali niente cerimonia il mio
fidanzato mi ha chiesto di sposarlo a
giugno ma io non sarei mai una brava
moglie per nessuno dite a mio padre che
evidentemente ho fin troppe cose in
comune con mia madre
due cose mi hanno legato subito a lei
quell'espressione buona moglie che
esattamente come buona madre avevano per
me un significato chiaro senza che
nessuna di noi due si fosse spiegata a
distanza di settant'anni
quell etichetta è rimasta intatta ha
superato il millennio ed evidentemente a
lei faceva lo stesso schifo che faceva a
me e poi il riferimento a qualcosa di
generico e di sbagliato che la legava a
sua madre delle cose una trasmissione di
errore che mi chiamava direttamente in
causa
quella notte ho adottato il cadavere di
evelyn mccain è lei a tutta toman che
avevo bisogno di un amica che mi
aiutasse a ridare senso alla mia vita ho
dedicato i successivi otto anni a capire
chi fosse quella ragazza qual era la sua
storia il significato delle sue parole
che cosa l'avesse portata lì o poi
scritto un romanzo su questa storia è
come sempre succede
la storia di una donna conteneva la
storia di molte donne un intero secolo
di donne
evelyn mchale è nata nel 1923 a berkeley
in california era la sesta di sette
figli
sua madre si chiamava helen ed è stata
per moltissimo tempo una buona moglie ed
una brava madre e poi ha smesso suo
padre si chiamava vincent era un uomo in
carriera e la sua famiglia era parte di
questa carriera lavorava per la federal
bank in un momento in cui dopo il grande
crack e poi con il new deal il grande
sistema bancario americano cresceva
avere una famiglia numerosa
aveva un valore anche in termini di
reputazione così helen faceva i figli 7
badava alla casa e traslocava a ogni
nuova promozione del marito e poi a un
certo punto non ce l'ha fatta più
nel 1930 la famiglia arriva a washington
evelyn a sette anni e sua madre comincia
a dare i segni di una profonda
depressione e se non fosse stata
depressione se fosse stata solo una
donna insoddisfatta di una vita al
servizio del marito stufa di essere il
migliore dei suoi biglietti da visita
se non fosse stata depressione se fosse
stata solo una persona infelice una
donna infelice ma non avesse nessuno che
avesse valore alla sua infelicità quando
leggiamo i libri di storia troviamo
delle date molto precise 1912 la marcia
per il voto a new york 1916 l'apertura
della prima clinica per la
pianificazione delle nascite a brooklyn
1917 la contestazione del presidente
wilson nell'arresto di 218 donne nello
stesso anno
l'arruolamento in massa delle donne in
marina 1921 la fondazione della ibl sì
la lega americana per il controllo delle
nascite che afferma per la prima volta
che i figli devono nascere anche dal
desiderio consapevole della madre e che
devono essere concepiti nell'amore e non
nella violenza questa è la storia ma
cosa succedeva nelle cucine delle donne
come la signora elena mackail smith
ancora oggi dopo tanti anni ignoro il
motivo per cui helen abbia lasciato i
suoi figli se ne sia andata da casa o
sia stata mandata via
se anche avesse una ragione un motivo
malessere profondo
nessuno si è curato di farcelo sapere
suo marito vincent ottiene la custodia
di tutti i figli anche quelle minorenni
li porta con sé a takako a new york
qui evelyn finisce di frequentare le
scuole superiori e poi si arruola
nell'esercito nelle works and women's
army corps che sono quasi sempre assenti
dai libri di storia
eppure le donne sono state
indispensabili per la vittoria americana
nel secondo conflitto mondiale sono
state arruolate dopo tutti gli altri
persino dopo i neri
eppure sono diventate le migliori anche
nelle armi air force l'aeronautica
militare erano 40.000 le donne arruolate
nel 45 sono in missione all'estero con
oltre 200 ruoli professionali diversi un
esercito nell'esercito ma l'esercito più
potente d'america era quello delle
massaie rimaste a casa
il presidente hoover ricorda che durante
la guerra le munizioni più preziosi
erano le bistecche e i tagli pregiati di
carne da mandare al fronte per mantenere
i soldati in forza e in salute
per questo nel 41 viene creato un
comitato per le abitudini alimentari che
ha lo scopo di istruire allora insaputa
le massaie a cucinare per i figli e
mariti piatti con ingredienti definiti
esotici per non dire schifosi lingua
trippa interiora cuore fegato tutto
quello che rimane dopo i tagli pregiati
di carne nel 45 quando la guerra finisce
evelyne a new york abita con il fratello
e la cognata e lavora come impiegata nel
distretto finanziario di manhattan a una
sauna festa una sera conosce l'uomo che
le chiederà di sposarla ha un anno in
più di lei si chiama beirut è un
veterano come lei della guerra un ex
pilota dell'aeronautica che frequenta la
facoltà di ingegneria a lafayette
college a easton in pennsylvania
barry era uno che prima della guerra non
poteva studiare ma da veterano
l'università gliela paga lo stato
quando finisce la guerra e fino al
settembre del 46 viene attuato una
grande operazione si chiama tappeto
magico col compito di reintegrare nella
vita civile un esercito di 16 milioni di
militari per il 97 per cento uomini per
reinserire questa massa di uomini adulti
nella vita civile
il presidente roosevelt film un
provvedimento che è passato alla storia
come jia e bill una grande copertura un
grande investimento di 500 milioni di
dollari che offre tra l'altro delle
borse di studio per frequentare
l'università
il jb è un grande successo quattro anni
dopo la fine della guerra nel 49 il 70
per cento dei laureati è un ex militare
l'investimento pubblico nella
qualificazione degli ex militari è
fondamentale per il rilancio economico
degli stati uniti nel dopoguerra e sulla
carta il g a e b la il primo
provvedimento che sostiene il capitale
umano senza di schemi
azione di razza o di sesso questa è la
storia ma per quelli come veline come
barry le cose andarono un po
diversamente
anche le veterane invasori college e
naturalmente ma per loro la formazione
universitaria la qualificazione non ebbe
un effetto positivo al contrario alla
vigilia della guerra lavorava una donna
su due
nel 1950 sono una su tre parte delle
coperture finanziarie
vennero trovate tagliando servizi che
avevano sostenuto il lavoro femminile in
tempo di guerra come gli asili pubblici
sondaggi condotti molti anni dopo
rivelarono che alle donne che chiesero
di mantenere il lavoro con cui avevano
sfamato la famiglia in tempo di guerra
vennero imposti tagli di orario di
stipendio fino all'ottanta per cento
man mano che uscivano dai college alle
donne vennero levate le posizioni di
comando vennero negate le promozioni non
potevano accedere alle cattedre
prestigiose vennero loro negati i
riconoscimenti
immagino che questo non vi sorprende il
soffitto di cristallo
esattamente come le pressioni sociali è
una costruzione socio economica che pesa
sulle spalle di tutti noi
da troppo tempo nel 1945
evelyn mchale è una giovane donna che
vive e lavora a new york e fa progetti
per il suo futuro
nel 1947 è una giovane donna che si
uccide scrivendo nel suo biglietto
d'addio
non sarò mai la brava moglie di nessuno
possibile che nel grande sogno americano
del dopoguerra non ci fossero
alternative per lei
ho iniziato questo talk raccontandovi di
come sono diventata amica di una ragazza
fantasma rimettere insieme i frammenti
della sua vita mi ha aiutato a capire
che il mondo in cui io da donna da
professionista da mamma mi sento a
disagio è il risultato di una lunga
somma di tradimenti ai danni di tutte le
donne la guerra di genere è l'unica che
non è mai finita nel novecento la
crescita delle democrazie non è incluso
le donne come cittadini si è limitata a
considera a considerarle strumenti a
dividerle tra utili e inutili
ancora oggi a ogni piccola conquista
nella vita pubblica come in quella
privata sottilmente più o meno
esplicitamente dobbiamo rispondere
sempre alla stessa domanda a che cosa
servono le donne
bene è il momento di rispondere
le donne non sono funzioni la buona
moglie la brava madre la donna dietro un
grande uomo
quella che cura quella che accudisce le
donne non sono funzioni sono persone
finché questa non sarà una verità per
tutti
finché le nostre democrazie saranno
sordi alla rivendicazione delle donne
finché u miller hanno la loro rabbia
finché il confronto non avverrà su un
altro piano allora continueremo a vedere
donne di qualsiasi età che si rifiutano
di abbassare la testa di chiedere scusa
di essere relegati a un ruolo di mera
utilità e che piuttosto di essere
confinate se ne andranno da questo mondo
facendo un grande vertiginoso salto
[Applauso]
da quando è arrivata mia figlia mi ha
insegnato che la vita è un cammino che
facciamo mano nella mano lungo la grande
strada della storia che tracciamo
insieme
e i libri delle date sono scritti dagli
uomini e questa è una grande notizia
perché abbiamo ancora da scrivere la
storia delle donne
se oggi sono femminista se riconosco
sostengo e supporto le rivendicazioni
delle donne del mio tempo è perché ho
con me i fantasmi di tutte le donne
della storia l'esercito delle pessime
mogli che hanno combattuto per essere
persone chi sono queste donne dobbiamo
sforzarci di ricordarci di loro di che
persona erano e non sono a che cosa sono
servite il primo maggio del 1947 il
corpo di evelyn mchale è precipitato su
una limousine quell'auto apparteneva a
un uomo che stava scrivendo insieme a
molti uomini e poche donne quella che
l'anno successivo sarebbe diventata la
dichiarazione universale dei diritti
dell'uomo 70 anni fa ci sono voluti 65
anni perché le nazioni unite rendessero
operativo un ente che si occupasse di
realizzare pienamente l'articolo 1 di
quella dichiarazione per il primo
soggetto di violenza discriminazione e
repressione le donne di tutto il mondo
siamo alla fine di una storia e siamo
nel mezzo di una nuova grande storia
quale sarà questa storia dipende da
tutti noi insieme è il momento di
ricordarci che esiste un'altra storia
più complessa quotidiana e collettiva
insieme è quella fatta anche da molte
moltissime donne è il momento di
ricucire i frammenti delle loro vite
come persone e come protagonisti degli
eventi è il momento di riaverle qui con
noi perché siano le ombre benevole le
radici vive di tutte le rivendicazioni
che ancora oggi le donne chiedono in
tutte le parti del mondo perché oggi più
che mai women's rights and human rights
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]